bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 4 février
jean castex en appelle à la mobilisation
des français pour que l'épidémie reste
sous contrôle
une situation sanitaire fragile qui ne
justifie pas à ce jour de nouveau
confinement nouvel arrivant dès samedi
pour les soignants le vaccin est rasé
les cas les variants source d'inquiétude
pour leur contagiosité alors que celui
d'origine brésilienne a été détectée sur
le territoire français
pas de limitations de déplacements entre
régions pendant les vacances d'hiver
pour l'instant en tout cas
le chef de la diplomatie européenne en
visite à moscou une première depuis 2010
est l'espagnol josep borrell doit
rencontrer son homologue sergueï lavrov
une conférence de presse est attendu
demain matin au coeur des discussions le
nucléaire iranien les vaccins ou encore
le climat
le tout avec en toile de fond lahaye
faire alexeï navalni elle nouvelles
frictions of bricks site entre l'europe
et le royaume uni confronté à des
retards de livraison de vaccins
bruxelles a voulu introduire un
mécanisme de contrôle des exportations
et qui devait initialement concernées
d'irlande du nord avant de finalement y
renoncer
dans l'east london met en pause lieux et
averti qu'il fera tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour que le processus de paix
et l'unité du royaume uni soit respectée
[Musique]
et avant de revenir sur la conférence de
presse du premier ministre et du
ministre de la santé tout à l'heure les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire et la
précarité qui touche plusieurs secteurs
grève nationale et manifestations
partout en france aujourd'hui notamment
à paris plusieurs manches se sont
mobilisés dans la capitale entre les
places de la république et de la nation
pour l'emploi les salaires et le service
public parmi les manifestants des
syndicats des organisations de la
jeunesse et des acteurs du monde de la
culture notamment
on retrouve tout de suite en direct sur
place
katia pique nique bonsoir katia comment
s'est déroulée cette journée de
mobilisation
bonsoir stéphanie mais c'est une grande
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui une
journée qui s'est déroulée dans le calme
des milliers de manifestants ont défilé
entre la place de la république et de la
place de la nation je me trouve
actuellement
la manifestation s'est dispersée vers
17h alors je rappelle que c'était une
mobilisation interprofessionnelle à l'ap
à l'appel de l'intersyndicale cgt fsu
solidaires y avait également quatre
organisations de jeunes ainsi que des
gilet jaune
tout ça était là pour défendre l'emploi
et le service public alors avec un
accent particulier porté sur la culture
dont les métiers souffrent actuellement
les intermittents demandant la
prolongation de l'année blanche
c'est-à-dire la prolongation de leurs
droits alors pour ce qui est des
revendications écoutez je vous propose
d'entendre philippe martinez secrétaire
général de la cgt et benoîte est
secrétaire général de la fsu il faut que
la colère pour croise tous les jours
il y a dans les entreprises puis elle
puisse s'exprimer donc c'est un appel à
dire oh il faut que nos revendications
sont attendus à santé ça fait des années
que ça dure
est-ce qu'on tire les leçons de la
période où est-ce qu'on continue à
fermer des lits dans l'éducation
léon on continue à supprimer les emplois
éducation dans l'éducation dans les
services publics et puis dans les
entreprises on parle de relancer le
gouvernement a dit faut relancer le
ferroviaire le fret les trains de nuit
ben c'est des milliers d'emplois ça donc
il ya des tas d'endroits où on peut
créer des emplois la situation elle est
compliquée pour le service public parce
que on a le sentiment que tout le monde
est dans des préoccupations très
immédiates mais qu' on n'est pas en
train de préparer l'avenir et par
exemple si je vous donne un exemple on
est en train de supprimer des postes
dans les collèges et les lycées de
personnels enseignants mais aussi en
crée pas de nouveaux postes de
personnels éducatifs d'agents
territoriaux etc et donc on est en train
de s'opérer l'avenir de
de gâcher l'avenir pour la prochaine
rentrée on ne va pas avoir suffisamment
de profs et de personnel en face des
élèves à une époque où il faudrait au
contraire investir dans l'éducation
alors c'était un pari pour les syndicats
on ignorait combien de personnes
allaient venir et c'est un pari réussi
puisque jusqu'à 20000 personnes sont
venues en tout cas c'est un chiffre des
syndicats
mais au-delà de cette grande réunion
aujourd'hui
eh bien les syndicats auxquelles nous
avons parlé ont expliqué qu'une vague de
contestation et d'engagement durable
s'était créé quel que soit le contexte
de la pandémie
donc on peut imaginer qu'ils seront
prochainement encore sur le terrain
voilà en tout cas ce qu'il peut retenir
aujourd'hui de cette mobilisation
parisienne
merci cassia technique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de la place de la
nation conférence de presse tout à
l'heure dans de jean castex accompagné
de quatre ministres la situation
sanitaire ne justifie pas ce jour de
nouveau confinement
mais l'exécutif n'hésitera pas à prendre
ses responsabilités en cas de
dégradation forte et rapide des
indicateurs sanitaires et stratégies
tester tracé isolé reste le mot d'ordre
les mesures actuelles sont renforcées le
télétravail notamment qui devient
impératif côté campagne vaccinale le
calendrier
décliné en 7 millions de rendez-vous
vont ouvrir pour se faire vacciner dans
les prochains jours écouté un nouveau
confinement ne peut s'envisager qu'en
tout dernier recours
la situation ne justifie pas à ce jour
notre niveau d'incidence est certes
élevé mais il reste encore très
inférieur à ce qu'il était en octobre
dernier alors même que nous dépistons
toujours autant vous disant cela je veux
être clair si nous y sommes contraints
en cas de dégradation forte et rapide de
la situation
nous n'hésiterions pas à prendre nos
responsabilités l'objectif que nous
devons nous fixer ce n'est pas de
retarder cette échéance c'est de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour l'éviter et pour
revenir sur la situation sanitaire et
les dernières annonces place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christophe nguyen psychologue du travail
président du cabinet empreinte humaine
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
vincent jean brun maire de l'haÿ les
roses dans le val de marne président du
groupe libre républicains et
indépendants à la région ile-de-france
bonsoir a tous des trois merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc
une bonne heure de conférence de presse
auquel maintenant nous sommes habitués
alors pas de grande annonce sans
surprise le gouvernement se tient pas de
confier au confinement pour le moment
bones ou c'est reculer pour mieux sauter
bertrand legrand et bien je pense que
c'est une excellente chose
on a la chance d'avoir des français qui
sont responsables qui ont compris
maintenant la probable parler des gestes
barrières etc c'est la difficulté qu'on
a si jamais les contacts sociaux sociaux
se multiplient et donc du coup on voit
bien que on arrive à maintenir un peu le
la flambée épidémique et notamment la
flambée du variant donc c'est plutôt bon
signe
après je ne sais pas si c'est à mettre
au crédit du gouvernement ou au crédit
du peuple français qui commencent à
comprendre les choses
ça c'est un autre problème vincent jean
brun justement bertrand legrand fait
allusion voilà au peuple français qui a
commencé un petit peu à se révolter ici
ou là on en était pas aux manifestations
des autres pays dans le même temps nous
n'étions pas confiné sa pesée vous pensé
dans ses décisions du gouvernement en
tout cas de celle d'emmanuel macron vis
n'avait pas l'air tellement d'accord
avec le premier ministre
on a senti qu'il y avait des tensions au
plus haut niveau du gouvernement et même
s'ils ont effectivement mais on est tous
très heureux que le confinement ne tombe
pas sur la tête
on sent bien qu'il est encore prêt à
dégainer et donc on peut se réjouir
comme l'a dit le précédent intervenants
que les français maîtrisent ce variant
et c'est vrai que je préfère le ton du
premier ministre ce soir à celui d'
emmanuel macron il ya quelques temps
encore or quand il était préfet de 66
millions procureur nous ne sommes pas
des procureurs comme simplement des
sites
rien qui plaçons notre confiance dans un
gouvernement dont on attend qu'il gère
au mieux cette crise
alors il est clair que cette prise n'est
pas facile à gérer pour autant on est en
droit d'attendre de la transparence que
nous a promis premier ministre ce soir
on est en droit d'attendre du respect
des concitoyens qu'on n'a pas traité le
procureur et au respect vis-à-vis des
élus locaux et de leur équipe puisque on
a beaucoup entendu un ministre de la
santé expliqué que s'il y avait des
cafouillages dans la campagne de
vaccination c'était un peu la faute des
maires quand même équipe à la finale de
se plaindre
donc j'espère au moins que ce soir
d'avoir donné un premier ministre qui
commençait dans une logique de main
tendue et où il a remercié les maires il
a remercié les français on se dit que
côté ce qui commence à écouter un petit
peu le peuple et vous avez raison de le
dire un peuple qui en a assez et à bout
de souffle je le vis tous les jours dans
ma commune les personnes âgées notamment
qui me disent quand arrivent les vaccins
parce que tant qu'on n'a pas le vaccin
on peut plus voir de famille on peut pas
voir le petit enfant et ça a duré depuis
damas on y reviendra justement sur ce
vaccin puisque l'une des annonces
c'était évidemment on ne confirme pas
mais on renforce les mesures notamment
le télétravail que elisabeth bornes vote
augmentés veut multiplier je vous
propose d'écouter la ministre notre
objectif c'est que ces quelques 2,5
millions de salariés se mettent ou se
remettent à télétravailler la deuxième
priorité c'est que des salariés qui
télétravaillent aujourd'hui un deux ou
trois jours par semaine
face au moins un jour de télétravail en
plus chaque jour compte s'agissant des
salariés qui télétravaillent à 100% nous
maintenant la possibilité de revenir sur
le lieu de travail un jour par semaine
pour celles et ceux qui en expriment le
besoin notamment s'ils souffrent
d'isolement
alors christophe nguyen c'est un sujet
que vous connaissez parfaitement le
rappelle vous êtes psychologue du
travail
vous avez
alarmés récemment sur la détresse
psychologique est là et bien on n'entend
qu'eux ont veulent augmenter ce
télétravail on veux le respecter au
maximum quelle est votre réaction
moi je dirais que quand on écoute madame
bornes veux parler du 100% télétravail
je trouve qu'il ya une avancée qui date
on va dire de la fin de l'année dernière
dans la prise en compte finalement des
effets délétères en matière de santé
mentale de l'imposition du 100%
télétravail parce que ça pèse sur la
santé mentale dans le temps notamment
parce que ça d'élite les liens sociaux
sacré d'isolement et puis on voit qu'il
ya une forme d'appauvrissement aussi une
expérience du travail pour les
télétravailleurs donc dans le temps moi
ce que je pourrais dire c'est que
l'enjeu est effectivement de trouver la
juste mesure le bon équilibre entre des
actions des mesures sanitaires qui
peuvent créer de l' isolement et
l'impact psychologique psychosocial que
ça peut avoir et des mesures
d'accompagnement et je trouve que mettre
en place une ligne téléphonique d'écouté
psychologique on va dire en contrepartie
d une imposition du 100% télétravail
c'est bien on voit qu'il ya plus de
vingt mille appels de ce que j'ai
compris et par jour pour les
télétravailleurs en tant que tel
donc on voit qu'il ya un vrai besoin une
vraie détresse mais en tant que tel je
pense qu'il faut aller un peu plus loin
dans l'accompagnement psychologique
guider plus les employeurs pour faire de
la prévention et pas uniquement si vous
voulez proposer un service public de
soutien psychologique
bertrand legrand on entendait les
ministres en substance un jeune et plus
les mots exacts mais nous dire voilà on
pourrait beaucoup plus très télé
travailler il ya un certain nombre qui
se rendent sur les lieux de travail
alors qu'ils pourraient en fait rester
chez eux pour travailler
c'est une attitude qu'il faut désormais
éviter les contaminations ce fait ont
beaucoup sur le lieu de travail comme
avait l'air de la firme et jean castex
alors oui les contaminations ce sont
surtout les endroits où il ya un
nombre d'interactions sociales
importantes et donc évidemment sur les
lieux de travail
c'est tout à fait logique surtout si
c'est un lieu de travail confinée après
je suis parce que c'est du télétravail
je comprends parfaitement ce que ça peut
vouloir dire de s'isoler et la
difficulté psychologique qu'on peut
avoir à s'isoler moi-même quand j'ai dû
faire de la télé médecine s'étaient pas
brillant brillant je veux je peux vous
le garantir
et c'était pas terrible pour le moral
donc je comprends parfaitement qu'il ya
des métiers qui sont difficiles à
exercer en télétravail tout ce qui est
possible que de limitation
d'interactions sociales que ce soit au
travail ou en famille dans la sphère
privée
chaque fois qu'on évite une à une
interaction sociale on évite une
propagation du virus s'est
malheureusement comme ça qu'il faut
faire après faut un juste milieu entre
la santé mentale de la personne qui est
pratique et puis et puis le ski peut
faire non pas d'interaction sociale mais
tout de même des écoles qui restent
ouvertes avec un renforcement des
protocoles sanitaires dans plusieurs
écoles maternelles mais aussi collège
désormais quand il ya un cas de variants
on ferme la classe olivier viron s'est
exprimée justement sur ces écoles avec
un nouveau dispositif qui va être mis en
place après les vacances scolaires je
vous propose d'écouter le ministre de la
santé de manière à renforcer
l'acceptabilité du test qui peut ne pas
être agréable quand on est petit nous
attendons l'avis de la haute autorité de
santé sous dix jours qui nous permettra
d' employer des techniques de
prélèvement nouvelle par prélèvement
salivaire dans des conditions que la
haute autorité de santé devra préciser
sans attendre ne nous équiperons et nous
déploierons ces techniques pour que
retour des vacances scolaires nous
puissions réaliser plusieurs centaines
de milliers de tests par prélèvement
salivaire vincent genvrin une bonne
chose
on imagine que vous allez y et les roses
ya évidemment beaucoup d'administrés qui
viennent vers vous avec cette inquiétude
beaucoup de parents qui ont leurs
enfants à l'école les tests salivaires
c'est la solution justement pour
justement appliquée tester
isolé protéger ils ont attendu
effectivement avec beaucoup d'impatience
parce qu'on voit bien un test pcr par le
nez c'est extrêmement gênant et pour les
enfants ça paraît un peu un consommable
mois elle simplement
ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on entend le
ministre de la santé nous parler d'un
nouveau dispositif de la même manière
qu'il avait annoncé l'arrivée des
vaccins en disant nous allons vacciner
nous allons ouvrir des centres nounou
nul
la question c'est qui est ce nous moi je
serais très curieux de savoir qui va
pratiquer les tests salivaires
est ce que quand monsieur mise la santé
dit nous est ce qu il compte sur
l'éducation nationale est ce qu il
compte une fois de plus mobilisés à les
municipalités et leurs agents là encore
je pense que comme il s'agit de sauver
des vies nous seront évidemment présents
et nous répondrons à l'appel mais ça
serait fort sympathique d'être
préalablement concertée ce serait fort
aimable de sa part de réunir un
collectif de mères pour réfléchir avec
eux sur les modalités parce que au-delà
de ces tests qui sont une bonne nouvelle
on a également mis en place sans aucune
concertation
un nouveau protocole sanitaire dans
lequel on nous explique que maintenant
qu on fait tout comme en garde les
écoles ouvertes les cantines ouverte
mais par contre maintenant il faut une
distanciation de mètres au lieu d'un
mètre c'est mission quasi impossible
et autant vous dire que là aussi c'est
bien beau de passer à la télé pour faire
des annonces encore faut-il que ça suit
plus sur le terrain et pour ça ça passe
par une meilleure concertation avec les
élus qui encore une fois toutes
tendances politiques confondues veulent
réussir la campagne vaccinale veulent
réussir toutes ces mesures barrières et
ses protocoles nouveau on va être des
partenaires vous passez des adversaires
sentiment de ne pas être accompagnées
parce que c'est peut-être qu'on aura
aussi on simple administrés quand on a
des enfants à l'école on apprend voilà
par la directrice de l'établissement
telle ou telle mesure
mr parfois s'en mêle aussi vous êtes
également abandonné de ces mesures on
vous laisse un petit peu vous
débrouiller en tout cas le service après
vente si j'ose dire mais c'est
clairement ça c'était à que le fameux
nouveau protocole sanitaire
on l'a découvert dans la presse il a été
équipé dans le texte fin dans le décret
qui est sorti sans être spécialement mis
en avant donc bien fallu aller chercher
l'information ne vient même pas jusqu'à
nous nous qu'est-ce qu'on répond quand
effectivement une classe est fermée
parce qu'il ya des quatre co vide
positif est que les parents d'élèves
nous tombe dessus en disant mais qu'est
ce que vous avez prévu comme celui sur
un garde pour mon enfant
ben en fait c'est très compliqué puisque
en réalité il ya une sorte de consignes
de l'éducation nationale qui consiste à
dire maintenant si justement il ya un
cas il faut que tous les autres enfants
restent chez eux sauf que c'est
l'éducation nationale ne gère pas
forcément cette communication
donc ça retombe systématiquement sur la
tête des mères qui pour le moment faute
de concertation faute de communication
faute de dialogue gère toute manière un
peu artisanal chacun fait de son mieux
avec les moyens qu'il a c'est pas
vraiment digne d'un grand pays comme la
france est objectivement on pourrait
attendre autre chose d'un gouvernement
qui prépare cette campagne vaccinale qui
gère maintenant depuis plus d'un an
cette crise on se dit qu'effectivement
il est temps que le gouvernement
réunissent les mains christophe nguyen
c'est peut-être moins votre domaine mais
ça reste tout de même le travail pour
eux vous vous en voyez vous en entendez
des directeurs d'établissements même des
professeurs parce que nous les voir en
tant que parents ils ont l'air parfois
fort démunis avec beaucoup de
responsabilités finalement sur les
épaules oui et puis l'épuisement général
qui concerne l'ensemble des sphères de
la société
on voit que il s'accumule dans le temps
et que cette détresse touche toutes les
populations en tant que tel et peut-être
les plus fragilisées au départ mais on
voit bien que les echets on va dire de
la détresse psychologique sur les
troubles mentaux qui commencent à
apparaître sur une plus grande large
frange de population on va dire à des
effets qui sont différées c'est dans le
temps tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
tout ce que tout ce qui se prépare et
toutes les décisions qui sont mises en
oeuvres auront un impact psychologique
dans les futurs mois donc on voit
qu'effectivement l'ensemble des
composantes de la société concernée et
ce qui me paraît essentiel en matière de
protection de la santé mentale c'est
d'avoir une vision un petit peu globale
en matière de santé avoir une certaine
forme aussi d'unité on a vu aussi les
tergiversations qui a pu avoir autour de
l'annnonce du confinement et qui crée de
l'anxiété
si vous voulez donc c'était se nourrit
de ses hésitations de ses contradictions
de ce nombre d'unités et je pense qu'on
s'en sortira que quand on pourra
effectivement s'appuyer sur de la
solidarité humaine et qui est un vecteur
très important pour la résilience des
personnes alors la lutte contre la
pandémie évidemment ça passe par la
vaccination il en a été beaucoup
question lors de cette conférence de
presse vous propose tout d'abord
d'écouter jean castex qui évoque ça va
faire plaisir aux docteurs le grand que
l'on va faire réagir dans quelques
instants qui évoque la vaccination de
ville en ville plutôt la haute autorité
de santé a autorisé hier l'utilisation
d'un nouveau vaccin en france le vaccin
astrazeneca cela va nous permettre
d'accélérer le rythme de vaccination
grâce à ce nouveau vaccin nous pourrons
atteindre l'objectif de 4 millions de
personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection
d'ici la fin du mois de février et la
vaccination
je vous annonce devrait commencer dès ce
samedi les conditions de conservation de
ce vaccin moins complexe que les deux
premiers nous permettront de confier
ensuite d'ici la fin de ce mois aux
professionnels de santé de ville médecin
généraliste pharmaciens et infirmiers la
suite de cette campagne vaccinale
les deux informations données par le
premier ministre à l'arrivée du vaccin
astrazeneca qui n'est pas une surprise
la vaccination d'ondés
samedi et puis donc bertrand legrand je
sens que ça va vous faire plaisir la
vaccination qu'on va pouvoir faire en
vilain par les médecins que vous êtes on
vous a récupéré par téléphone
c'est une vraie bonne nouvelle cela pour
vous oui
la bonne nouvelle la vaccination dans
les cabinets de médecine générale
parce qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les statistiques par exemple
sur que vie de traqueur que le la
vaccination a raté sa cible
on avait pour but de vacciner
essentiellement des personnes de plus de
75 ans et des personnes à risque et
force est de constater que la
vaccination dans les vaccinodromes qui
ressemble vraiment à l'âme et nicole
cause yen a atteint les objectifs de des
fonctionnaires qui travaillait dans c
dans ces hôpitaux
donc on a raté l'objectif est très clair
on n'arrive pas à fournir avec saint lô
personnes de 75 ans et les personnes de
75 ans et plus n'ont même pas envie
d'aller à l'hôpital pour se faire
vacciner donc clairement si on continue
comme ça on va droit dans le mur
et deuxième chose ça me fait plaisir que
on me dit que bientôt je vais avoir des
doses mais comme ça fait un mois qu'on
me dit que je vais avoir des doses je
leur ai fait un petit peu méfiant sur la
question et surtout c'est une énorme
déception c'est de savoir que le vaccin
le moinde efficace celui qui a le taux
d'efficacité le plus faible est réservé
aux soignants très franchement je
comprend beaucoup mieux que certain
nombre de confrères ou de personnes
travaillant dans les hôpitaux se sont
précipités pour aller chercher le vaccin
de pfizer alors même qu'il y avait moins
50 concernant en tout cas les pénuries
de vaccination est le premier ministre
essayez d'être rassurant 1,5 million de
vaccinations prévues bientôt un des
rendez vous prévus 500000 rendez vous
fin février 7,1 millions de rendez vous
qui se découperont par dont 500000
rendez vous fin février voilà qui est
plus clair
on essaye voilà de progresser nous y
croyez vous à cette progression vincent
jean brun il faut y croire même si je
partage a aussi ce qui a été dit par les
intervenants précédents à savoir que ça
fait des semaines pour pas dire des mois
qu'on nous dit
dès la semaine prochaine plein de choses
arrive en complément tenez bon tenez bon
les choses arrivent le problème c'est
qu'effectivement on a un nouveau vaccin
qui arrive dans combien de temps
sera-t-il disponible dans les
vaccinodromes le premier ministre ne l'a
pas dit on n'en sait rien faudra-t-il ce
vaccin là comme le finder aller le
chercher nous mêmes dans les hôpitaux
pour l'instant aucune information
logistique ne nous est fourni et puis
derrière effectivement quelle
frustration d'apprendre que ce vaccin ne
permettra pas de vacciner les plus de 65
ans elle pendant les plus wii + 65 ans
sachant que dans un maximum rom comme le
mien on vaccine à peu près une
cinquantaine de personnes par jour et on
a une liste d'attentes de plus de 5000
personnes 5000 personnes sur deux
injections vous visualisez il faut faire
dix mille injection pour vacciner tout
le monde
un rythme de 50 injections par jour ce
n'est pas tenable et malheureusement ma
crainte c'est qu'astrazeneca qui est il
faut le dire quand même une bonne
nouvelle
soit une petite bonne nouvelle par
rapport à l'ampleur et et aux enjeux
qu'on doit affronter le gouvernement là
aussi a tenté d'être rassurant puisque
quatre vaccins seront produits en france
peut-être un de quoi augmenter la
production en tout cas de palier
à la pénurie de médecins sont propose
d'écouter agnès pannier grenache et la
france contribuera à produire dès les
prochains mois quatre vaccins en france
le moderna à partir du mois de mars le
bâillon ntech à partir du mois d'avril
le curve ac si ce vaccin reçoit son
autorisation de mise sur le marché à
partir du mois de mai et le sanofi à
partir du mois de juin ceci le fruit
d'un travail entamé dès juin dernier
2020 par le gouvernement s'agissant des
vaccins moderna by one tech et curve ac
puisque nous avons accompagné et financé
les lignes de production dans trois
sites industriels français qui vont
accueillir ses productions bertrand
legrand de quoi accéder à la promesse
emmanuel macron de se faire tous
vaccinés d'ici la fin de l'été ses
productions sur le sol français ça
devrait accélérer les choses prévues
d'ici la fin de l'été ça paraît quand
même les promesses de politiciens on
nous a promis qu'on vaccine et que des
personnes de 75 ans et encore une fois
on regarde bien les chiffres on entend
bon mon prédécesseur et qui est mère au
dessus on écoute les politiques on est
entrain de vacciner que des gens de 75
ans mais quand on regarde les chiffres
c'est pas le cas donc non clairement je
pose se fâche et qui lui qu aucun doute
sur la question
il est très clair que nous manquons de
vaccins et il est très clair que nous
n'aurons pas des vaccins parce que nous
n'avons pas passé la commande en bonne
et due forme au bon moment
on nie le problème il y en a c'est juste
qu'on a pas que les commandes trop tard
merci en tout cas tous les trois à
christophe nguyen bertrand legrand
vincent jean brun d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france pour commenter
donc ces annonces en tout cas ce bidon
de jean castex aujourd'hui sur la lutte
contre le coronavirus donc quelques
instants rester avec nous vous parlerons
de la visite du chef de la diplomatie
européenne josep borrell en russie un
déplacement prévu
de longue date qui intervient dans un
contexte de turbulences avec la sphère
navali et puis direction le royaume uni
boris johnson met en pause l'union
européenne dans les frictions poste
breakes site en cause les retards de
livraison de vaccins
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort
du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose dignité
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir amitié
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
chapeau
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent en soi vient des
lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
d'user la natation
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez réunion moscou
bruxelles en cette fin de semaine c'est
une première depuis 2010 est un
représentant européen en visite en
russie
l'espagnol josep borrell est arrivé et
lui à moscou le chef de la diplomatie
européenne doit rencontrer notamment son
homologue sergueï lavrov d'une
conférence de presse est attendu demain
matin au coeur des discussions le
nucléaire iranien la pandémie de kobe 19
ou encore le climat
le tout avec en toile de fond la sphère
n'avait ni la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine clé route
l'union européenne attend des avancées
dont le dossier navalni à la suite du
verdict qui envoyait l'opposant russe en
prison pour un peu plus de deux ans et
demi de nombreux responsables
occidentaux ont demandé à l'unisson sa
libération immédiate
josette borel qui a maintenu son
déplacement à moscou malgré les
réticences de certains états membres a
lui même admis je cite qu'il
n'obtiendrait sans doute pas sa
libération
en effet le responsable européen est
attendu de pied ferme au ministère russe
des affaires étrangères où l'on estime
qu'un procès injuste est intentée contre
la russie on a l'impression que les
responsables occidentaux refusent tout
simplement de voir ce qui se passe dans
leur pays ce qui se passe ces jours même
dans l'union européenne ce qui se passe
c'est moi même aux états unis
il détourne délibérément l'attention de
l'opinion publique mondiale de la
situation dans leur pays
se focalisant sur leur vision de la
situation en russie
demain lors des discussions entre
sergueï lavrov et josep borrell haut
représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères
nous aborderons l'ensemble des questions
concernant les déclarations
inacceptables les pseudos évaluation la
distorsion des faits du côté du kremlin
on espère cependant que cette rencontre
sera constructive
malgré les tensions et les différences
de points de vue sur un très grand
nombre de dossiers nous attachons une
grande importance à la prochaine visite
de joseph bourrel
vous savez tous récemment
faisant le point sur les relations entre
moscou et bruxelles le président poutine
a déploré qu elles soient en fait je les
hais ce n'est pas la russie qui est à
l'origine de ce gel
bien évidemment nous souhaitons
débloquer notre dialogue tous azimuts
entre moscou et bruxelles notamment pour
discuter ouvertement et franchement de
l'ensemble des divergences qui sont
assez nombreuses
la rencontre entre sergueï lavrov et
josep borrell sera en tout cas scrutée
de près par les européens qui font
planer la menace de sanctions si leurs
exigences ne trouve pas un écho
favorable du côté des autorités russes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois pour les matiz journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe bonsoir en sorte
que les maîtres et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on le
sert le déplacement était prévu de
longue date
ils avaient pour objectif d'ailleurs de
renouer le dialogue avec moscou mais la
sphère navalni risque fort de peser lors
de cette visite du chef de la diplomatie
européenne
ah oui forcément ça m'a pesé parce que
il ya une certaine forme d'une a limité
parmi les pays occidentaux pour
condamner finalement cette mise au frais
entre guillemets de la vanille je crois
que les pays occidentaux ne se font pas
trop d'illusions sur le sens de leur
démarche et sur la possibilité de
résultats de leurs débats mais ils
veulent quand même marquer le coup et je
crois que effectivement josep borrell
est là pour bien indiquer que pour les
pays occidentaux l'arrestation de
navalni ne rentre pas dans un cadre de
démocratie de bon aloi et donc ça risque
effectivement de rendre la de la
situation un petit peu difficile mais
cela dit il ya beaucoup d'autres
dossiers et les relations entre la
russie et l'union européenne en
particulier
ce sont des choses qui comptent et donc
on peut éventuellement s'attendre à
quelques mini sanctions et encore je n'y
crois pas trop
et donc on verra un petit peu comme les
choses évoluer pour l'instant attendons
de voir
alors en tout cas la sphère navalni a
fait réagir assez promptement et
rapidement lé pays européens berlin
paris moscou elle parle d'ingérence de
la part de l'europe qu'il demandait la
libération immédiate index et annabelle
ni est ce que c'est le terme adéquat
l'ingérence j'ai eues on peut toujours
considérer qu'il y à un gérant ce dès le
moment où un finalement des pays
extérieurs met en cause des décisions
qui pourraient relever a priori de la
souveraineté d'un état
cela dit je pense que la russie comme
les autres états en sont membres
finalement d'une communauté
internationale et se sont engagés sur
des règles de respect d'une certaine
forme de la démocratie donc tout le
débat est là le débat et savoir est ce
que les décisions prises à l'encontre de
navalni rentre dans un cadre juridique
qui est acceptable vu du point de vue
des droits de l'homme
toute la question est là mais je pense
que la démarche josep borrell elle
s'appuiera sur cette question là pour
dire vous avez pris des engagements sur
le respect des droits de l'homme
est ce que on peut considérer que
finalement ces décisions prises à
l'encontre de naval y sont véritablement
des décisions acceptable par rapport à
vos propres engagements alors dans le
même temps à cette visite tombe au
moment où le vaccin foot ni kfw entre en
grâce un je n'irai après cette étude
favorable de hollande 7 la revue
scientifique de référence alors que
l'europe elle est en pleine pénurie il
va falloir faire un petit exercice
d'équilibrisme ben oui parce qu'il faut
que ce vaccin le axens pique nique il
faut qu'ils puissent passer les épreuves
par rapport à l'union européenne par
exemple il faut qu'ils passent les
épreuves d'être accepté par les
institutions sanitaires de l'europe une
union européenne mais globalement on
peut penser que cette opération devrait
se passer sans trop de problème dès le
moment où il est évident maintenant que
le vaccin scouter est un vaccin qui est
crédible
un vaccin qui semble parfaitement
efficace et donc on peut très bien
penser que ce pas que ça complètera la
gamme des vaccins qui actuellement sont
en préparation pour pouvoir être diffusé
sur le continent européen
donc je pense effectivement que le
vaccin ce boutique aura sa place parmi
les autres vaccins en tout cas
il ya eu voilà tous les commentateurs
s'accordent à le dire une certaine
idéologie par moments dans cette gestion
de la crise
on peut avoir totalement confiance à
l'agencé médicale européenne du
médicament pour son traitement par
rapport au vaccin russe je pense que
l'agencé européenne a été finalement
accepté finalement à 5,92 vaccin je
pense qu'elle a accepté les vaccins
américain il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle
n'accepte pas des vaccins d'autres
provenances mais cela dit cette crise du
coc vide c'est une crise qui est énorme
et qui d'une crise on a vu en europe
avec notamment les ratés de l'union
européenne notamment dans ses relations
avec la grande-bretagne
c'est une crise très difficile qui
aujourd'hui se cristallise sur un
problème qui est l'absence enfin le
manque de livraison suffisantes de
vaccins correspondre à la demande
donc on est vraiment dans cette
situation donc l'eau tous les vaccins
qui auront qui obtiendront finalement
l'agrément de l'agencé européenne du
médicament seront les bienvenus mais on
peut penser qu'une fois que cette phase
difficile d'accès aux vaccins et de
livraison des vaccins une fois que se
connaît nouveaux vaccins vont pouvoir
arriver je pense qu'on arrivera dans le
courant de l'année vers le mois d'été à
une relative normalisation
on a vu que dans cette affaire avec 100
russe et l allemagne 1 qui était plutôt
sur la première ligne qui se fait
l'avocate du vexin russe
tout le monde a l'air de suivre ce que
c'est c'est la bonne vision l'allemagne
et devant et le reste suit c'est ça
l'allemagne a toujours eu vis-à-vis de
cire lâchures dans le cadre de ses
relations avec la russie une situation
un petit peu particulière un petit peu
privilégié parce que pour l'allemagne
des relations avec la russie c'est
important on pense par exemple au projet
qui est quasiment terminée maintenant le
gazoduc qui relie l'europe et la russie
mais il ya d'autres domaines dans lequel
pour pour la même pour l'allemagne
les relations avec la russie sont
peut-être plus importantes qu'elles ne
paraissent pour d'autres pays de l'union
européenne comme la france ou d'eau
et donc c'est peut-être ça qui joue en
faveur de fectivement de la
bienveillance que l'allemagne peut avoir
par rapport à cette vague s'armer je
vous signale également que des pays
comme la hongrie n'ont pas attendu un
laisser-faire de laisser passer de
l'europe pour commander pour souhaiter
bénéficier de ce base de ce vaccin pour
elle même une dernière question sur les
points de convergence notamment
peut-être le nucléaire iranien qui sera
au coeur des débats où ce oui mais c'est
surtout là la nouveauté c'est le fait de
changer d' administration américaine
l'arrivée de joe bailly dead qui succède
à donald trump
rabat les cartes complètement sur le
nucléaire iranien saraba les cartes
aussi sur le climat puisque joe biden a
décidé de réintégrer l'accord de paris
est donc finalement là les conditions de
pouvoir avancer notamment sur ce dossier
iranien sur ce dossier-là biens sont
réunies pour que effectivement puisse
réellement c'est un dialogue mais c'est
un dialogue il faut pas se faire
d'illusions ça va pas un dialogue facile
et ça va pas ça un dialogue qui va
permettre tout de suite de raccommoder
avec l'ancien accord existant donc je
crois que les négociations risquent
d'être difficiles comme elle risque
d'être difficile sur l'ensemble du
domaine des relations transatlantiques
entre l'europe et les états unis entre
l'europe et la russie
il faut une certaine manière rebattre
les cartes et recommencer finalement à
zéro parce que effectivement les
conditions ont changé
merci beaucoup françois paul et mathis
journaliste spécialiste de l'europe de
nous avoir apporté votre éclairage
justement françois appelé m ils sont
parlés les retards de livraison de
vaccins anti kobe 19 et leurs
conséquences diplomatiques l'union
européenne annoncerait le durcissement
du contrôle des exportations ans de
l'irlande du nord
bien que bruxelles ait fait marche
arrière les premiers signes de tensions
apparaissent avec londres un mois
seulement après le break site
antoine auger le gouvernement
britannique semblait avoir trouvé un
terrain d'entente avec bruxelles le 24
décembre dernier mais se voit désormais
confrontés à de nouveaux heurts avec
l'union européenne le renforcement des
douanes instauré par lieu en irlande du
nord provoquent des tensions avec la
république d'irlande et fragilise
l'unité qui avait apporté l'accord de
paix du vendredi saint à cordes belfast
signé le 10 avril 1998
il est tout à fait regrettable que
l'union européenne semble jeter des
doutes sur l'accord du vendredi saint
les principes du processus de paix
ensemble en appeler à une frontière sur
l'île d'irlande et les unionistes qui
revendique pleinement leur appartenance
au royaume-uni voit d'un mauvais oeil la
différence de traitement entre les deux
irlande les murs de l'île ont été
recouverts de tags explicites contre
l'instauration de douane entre le
royaume uni et l'irlande du nord
les contrôles physiques ont été
suspendus dans les ports de belfast et
l'arn après des menaces sur les
douaniers un cri d'alarmé envoyé à
l'europe
concernant la situation sur l'île de
plus en plus de gens vont s'indigner et
je peux voir que c'est un problème
croissant qui affecte notre économie qui
affectent la vie des gens et qui ne sera
tout simplement pas accepter nous ne
voulons pas que des extrémistes prennent
pied mais il ya un réel danger que ce
soit le cas la première ministre
nord-irlandaise arlines foster qui
c'était vendredi dernier insurgé contre
bruxelles et avait qualifié je cite
d'actes d'agression la décision
d'introduire des règles strictes sur
l'exportation de vaccins du coc vide 19
a tenu à apaiser la situation en
déclarant que de telles menaces étaient
tout à fait répréhensible
des déclarations qui laissent penser que
le royaume uni est prêt à trouver des
solutions pour résoudre le litige
il oppose à bruxelles la commission
européenne n'a pour le moment pas réagi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec paul
thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur à paris bonsoir paul
thompson merci d'être avec nous et la
question d'irlande du nord à ses
frontières on le sait on le rappelle
elle a été pendant trois décennies le
théâtre de troupe très important
sanglant conflit évidemment qui oppose
et républicains catholiques partisans de
la réunification avec l'irlande
les vieux fantômes sont en train de se
réveiller
je ne pense que ça va se calmer assez
rapidement mais c'est vrai que c'était
un incident cette histoire d introduire
des contrôles sur la frontière entre la
république d'irlande et des vents du
nord a provoqué un chat qui certainement
un gang est tellement parce que pendant
dé toutes les années des négociations
sur le proxy que la commission
européenne ne cessait de dire qu'il ne
faut surtout pas que qu'il y ait qu ils
puissent avoir le moindre début de
frontières dur sur la sueur sur cette
frontière est et le fait de réclamer
elle même à des contrôles est en
contradiction flagrante avec cette
position donc c'était vraiment à une
bévue majeur mais il faut reconnaître
qu'elle était reconnu comme tel
rapidement et un d'ailleurs les antilles
breivik des progressions d'une
exceptions la même nature de la
situation et sommes continent aussi il
ya une quasi unanimité pour dire que
c'était vraiment une
une erreur assez grossière et
inexplicable de narok il s'agissait de
rectifier et et ça a été fait d'après ce
que je comprends à la commission a
renoncé à de total le contrôle donc donc
ça a été une source
un incident pénible mais qui je l'espère
en tout cas ne laisserait pas de de
marque durable en temps nos relations
entre
ou un mini l'union européen en tout cas
ça a été laborieusement négocié entre
bruxelles et londres à ce protocole
justement qu'ils visaient c'est le
comble à préserver le traité de paix de
l'accord du vendredi saint
manifestement un échec par quoi peut-on
remplacer comment peut-on finalement
régler cette situation il ya trois
questions je voulais en ce qui concerne
la préservation des acquis de l'accord
du vendredi saint à boris johnson va
ayila dit d'ailleurs dans de petites la
partie du sco que vous avez montré que
le gouvernement britannique et je suis
sûr qu'il est très sincère en e10 on
s'attache à préserver la substance de
cet accord et il ya laurent milliat tout
intérêt à la faire aussi pour assurer un
bon démarrage des rapports avec la
nouvelle administration
les nouveaux présidents américains mais
aussi parce que le dow a minina
simplement pas intérêt à créer d
encourager un dressage ans de troubles
que c'était très douloureux pour tout le
monde et y compris l'euro amis pour les
irlandais du nord et du sud est pour les
britanniques également
donc ça c'est le problème de points
généraux ce qui concerne le coût des
contrôles aux frontières je pense que la
question avait déjà été réglée la
rencontre entre le land du nord et la
république de vente
en ce qui concerne à la question des
contrôles dans la mer d'irlande comme on
dit c'est à dire entre les rangs du nord
et le reste du royaume uni ça c'est un
sujet une quantité plus difficile et je
ne sais pas comment savoir évoluer ma
vie je j'aurais tendance à croire que
le royaume uni ne voit pas s'employer à
éviscérer et dispositions pertinentes de
l'accord sur le retrait doit muni et et
il y avait une situation nouvelle où ces
contrôles sont nouveau c'est une source
d'irritation pour des personnes qui sont
directement concernés les commerçants
les particuliers même donc ça agace les
gens on peut espérer que ça se calme
avec avec l' usage de même que entre
calais et douvres il ya des quelques
frictions à côte ces nouveautés avec des
formulaires douaniers mais bon cette île
aura une courbe d'apprentissage comme on
dit qui fera j'espère que ça va se
calmer progressivement
c'était la guerre des vaccins qui était
à l'origine de ces nouvelles frictions
est ce qu'on doit tout de même
s'attendre à d'autres tensions
prochainement parce qu'on le sait la
situation est compliquée sur le terrain
concrètement je pense qu'il ya un jeu
intéressant qui dépensent les rangs du
nord les questions des vaccins aussi
importante que soient ces questions est
ce jeu général là le positionnement ou
rechercher respectivement par le groupe
le royaume uni son gouvernement d'une
part et la commission et de votre auto
dit rien d'autre part dans ce monde peut
se pratiquer à l'union de la droite unie
est très actif sur le front diplomatique
elle a déjà posé une demande d'adhésion
à cette zone de libre commerce au
pacifique où il ya déjà onze pays
elle a continué à conclure
des accords de libre commerce avec
différents pays léonard de la vase et
l'invs 302 mais il y a quinze jours il y
en a peut-être plus maintenant et je
pense que mon assurance et son équipe
parce qu'ils avaient été très soudé
capable
autour de lui des gens qui ont beaucoup
de personnalités qui sont des battants
veulent dire montrer au monde que le
royaume uni va utiliser cette
émancipation
bon on trouvait un grand mot pour agir
tous librement avec tous d'agilité dans
toutes sortes de domaines et il ya cette
affaire des vaccins est exploité je
pense que c'est assez évident maintenant
c'est de bonne guerre
à cette fin c'est-à-dire pour montrer
que justement de la reprise du contrôle
et la croix de 2,2 d'agilité de
souplesse de liberté de manoeuvre est
très payant y compris sur des sujets
d'importance vitale comme celui des
vaccins face c'est possible pandémie
donc il ya cette dimension politique
même métapolitique plus large qui joue
aussi
mais tout ça ne devrait pas empoisonner
durablement les rapports entre laurent
maunier du nord qui se savent ça fait
partie du jeu si vous voulez et donc il
ne faut pas à 100 moines s'en émouvoir
pendant ni sont inquiétés à mon avis
merci beaucoup pas là thomson vice
président du parti conservateur à paris
d'avoir été avec nous et dans le reste
de l'ue
et en turquie une nouvelle journée une
manifestation des étudiants cela fait
cinq mois que la contestation dure avec
de nouvelles revendications le président
turc affirme qu'il ne laissera pas cette
grogne estudiantine gagné de l'ampleur
hélène masquelier des centaines
d'étudiants dispersé violemment par la
police turque
une nouvelle journée de manifestations
pour un mouvement qui ne s'essouffle pas
malgré 170 arrestations ce mercredi la
colère estudiantine s'empare de diverses
thématiques féminicide sort des kurdes
dans le pays
et cette nouvelle revendication les
droits des personnes lgbt suite à
l'arrestation de quatre étudiants accusé
d'avoir insulté l'islam en cause
l'exposition d'un tableau représentant
la kaaba de la mecque ornée de drapeaux
arc en ciel face au mouvement le
président turc a réagi sans détour nous
ne considérons pas que ces jeunes qui
sont des membres d'organisations
terroristes ont véritablement les
valeurs nationales et morale de notre
pays à l'origine de la contestation la
nomination en début d'année
universitaire d'un proche de rld aux
ânes à la tête de l'université du
bosphore laquelle avait toujours réussi
à préserver une forme d'autonomie
si les étudiants réclament sa démission
le nouveau recteur ne semble pas près de
céder
je suis une personne qui défend les
droits et les libertés les lgbt
je ne pense absolument pas à
démissionner je m'attendais dès le
départ à ce que cette crise puisse
prendre six mois pour être résolus et ce
sera ainsi le président turc craint que
la contestation étudiante ne se
transforme en manifestation anti
gouvernement comme en 2013 dans un pays
en pleine crise économique
rachael tayyip erdogan se seraient
contestés et a déjà en ligne de mire la
future élection présidentielle
l'enjeu pour le président turc rallier
ses troupes et conserver sa position de
reis pour 2023
leucate au 2020 le port de la capitale
libanaise était dévastée par une énorme
explosion bilan plus de 200 morts et
6500 blessé des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont aujourd'hui encore sans
logement six mois après ce drame le
liban est dans une situation humanitaire
très grave et traverse aujourd'hui une
crise politique majeure et la medjahed
des centaines de familles ne peuvent
toujours pas faire leur deuil des
libanais qui attendent des réponses de
la justice sur les circonstances de
l'explosion du 4 août dernier des heures
des jours des semaines interminables
face à une enquête qui piétine
l enquête a jusqu'à présent été
complètement scandaleuse il n'y a pas de
transparence sur le lieu de l'enquète
une enquête criblé de violation de la
procédure régulière elle a été entachée
d'ingérence politique et aucun
responsable de haut niveau n'a été tenu
pour responsable au lieu de cela vous
avez 25 fonctionnaires des douanes et de
la sécurité portuaire qui croupissent en
prison tandis que les dirigeants
politiques se promènent librement et
échappe à toute responsabilité ou
obligation de rendre compte des
investigations pour expliquer comment
près de 3000 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium ont pu être entreposés dans
le port de beyrouth pendant des années
et en toute connaissance des risques
potentiels par les autorités une enquête
paralysé par des rivalités politiques
six mois après l'explosion il est
inacceptable que le liban n'est toujours
pas de gouvernement pour répondre à la
crise sanitaire et social et engagé les
réformes structurelles indispensables au
redressement et à la stabilité du pays à
tous les responsables de ce pays je
voudrais vous redire que votre
responsabilité individuelle et
collective est majeur ayez le courage
d'agir et la france vous aidera à paris
qui a tapé une nouvelle fois du poing
sur la table ce jeudi face à des
engagements restée lettre morte
le chef de la diplomatie française et
son homologue américain ont appelé le
liban à se doter sans plus tarder d'un
gouvernement condition sinequanone d'un
soutien à long terme de la communauté
internationale il y a un besoin urgent
et vital que les
responsables libanais met enfin en
oeuvre leurs engagements de former un
gouvernement crédible et efficace et de
travailler à la réalisation des réformes
nécessaires conformément aux aspirations
du peuple libanais ces actions concrètes
restent absolument nécessaire pour que
la france les états unis et leurs
partenaires régionaux et internationaux
s'engagent à apporter un soutien
supplémentaire structurelles et de long
terme au liban emmanuel macron s'est
rendu à deux reprises à beyrouth depuis
l'explosion du 4 août dernier le
président français a récemment annoncé
son intention d'y retourner pour fustigé
l'inaction des dirigeants libanais après
la déflagration le gouvernement a
démissionné mais il gère encore les
affaires courantes saad hariri désigné
premier ministre fin octobre n'a
toujours pas formé son équipe des
marchandages politiques qui perdure
alors que la ville de beyrouth se
reconstruit lentement et que la
population sombre dans la misère à
l'heure actuelle un libanais sur deux
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté
selon les nations unies soit 22% de plus
en seulement trois ans avec nous dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
le vexin rue spoutnik vais les premières
doses sont arrivés aujourd'hui en iran
l'europe espère pouvoir en obtenir plus
vite
l'italien exor le régulateur a accéléré
sa validation
et puis nous reviendrons sur la
conférence de presse tout à l'heure de
jean castex la situation ne justifie pas
à ce jour un nouveau confinement
[Musique]
les prévisions de croissance pour
l'année 2000 21 ont jamais été aussi
incertaine bien sûr que vous pouvez
avoir 6% à ce moment-là remettez sur la
table comme le font les états unis 2000
milliards et puis vous aurez de la
croissance simplement il faudra les
rembourser un jour une fois qu'on sera
dans la période dément l'atterrissage 9
à ce moment là il y aura un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui commenceront à
tomber
c'est là que l'on pourra faire l'état
des dégâts
je vous rappelle que ça n'est pas le
virus qui tue l'économie ce sont les
mesures qu'on a appliqué pour bloquer
l'économie
objectivement personne ne sait ce que
sera la croissance de la france mais
aussi de la plupart des pays européens
on peut simuler une croissance mais une
vraie croissance qui repose sur des
fondamentaux solides
vous n'êtes pas prêt de la voir
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement en énerver
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
majorque mâcon il passe un tour de
tracts avec nous et nos campagnes il
faut savoir cherubini ferrante ils ont
le sentiment d'être des français de
seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la minustah elle compte au moins
quatorze militaires et policiers
déployés au mali ont donc fait elle face
c'est une mission de paix des nations
unies
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle est connue
dans un monde difficile contre un ennemi
un ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui n'est pas essentiel qui ne
connaît pas la qualité qui est là pour
faire du mal mais grâce à notre
détermination nous sommes très
différents
on a le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sel pour les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace et le risque d'une menace pour le
bas et que sa réponse doit être plus
souvent là et la solidarité
robin
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 4 février après la méfiance
l'enthousiasmé le vaccin spots nick v
efficace à 91,6 % selon la revue
prestigieuse de l'endss est alors que
les premières doses sont arrivés
aujourd'hui en iran lors l'europe espère
bien aussi pouvoir en obtenir au plus
vite la hongrie elle a conclu un accord
pour en acheter jusqu'à 2 millions de
doses alors même que le régulateur
européen ne l'a pas encore validé
litanie exhorte à accélérer la procédure
jean castex en appelle à la mobilisation
des français pour que l'épidémie reste
sous contrôle une situation sanitaire
fragile qui ne justifie pas à ce jour de
nouveau confinement en france nouvel
arrivant dès samedi pour les soignants
le pex astrazeneca à l'école l'objectif
est de réaliser des tests de dépistage
salivaire les variants source
d'inquiétudes toujours on leur
contagiosité alors qu'un premier est
d'origine brésilienne a été détectée sur
le territoire français
en europe l'espagne un des pays les plus
touchés par la pandémie refuse de
recourir à l'armé ultime du confinement
et poursuit un objectif 70 % de vacciner
avant l'été outre-rhin c'est une lueur
d'espoir le gouvernement allemand ouvre
la porte 1 déconfinement avant la fin de
l'hiver
objectif alléger une situation qui met
les nerfs à vif en mai la chancelière
merkel est le danemark de son côté lens
le coran n'a pas sain passeport
numérique pour les personnes maxi à la
chasse aux vaccins qui se font rares le
royaume uni semble mieux loti alors que
d'autres comme la france voient leurs
campagnes de vaccination retardée alors
comment expliquer de telles différences
et retardant les vexin compromettent il
la reprise économique
autant de questions auxquelles jacques
sapir tentera de répondre dans l'édito
est court ce soir
[Musique]
après avoir été décriée par les médias
occidentaux pour avoir été produit et
mis rapidement en circulation en russie
le vexin russe coûte 1000 v semble
désormais suscité l'intérêt depuis
jeuland 7,1 depuis que seul en deux sets
le juge efficaces à +2 91% illustration
en italie où les conclusions de la revue
scientifique ont été accueilli très
positivement
le ministre italien de la santé a
rapporté avoir contacté l'agencé
européenne des médicaments afin
d'accélérer le processus d'évaluation du
vexin russe comme d'autres pays
européens l'italie doit faire face à une
pénurie dans les livraisons de vaccins
qui ralentit considérablement sa
campagne et en attendant spoutnik v est
déjà arrivée sur le sol iranien les
premières doses ont été remis à
l'aéroport de téhéran les deuxième et
troisième lot seront ensuite expédiés
courant et fin février
le pays est le plus durement touché par
la pandémie au proche-orient proche et
moyen-orient le kobe 19 a fait plus de
cinquante huit mille morts depuis
février 2020 en plus du vexin russe qui
rend recevra également 4,2 millions de
doses du vaccin astrazeneca dur en
février et pour parler du vexin russe
nous sommes en direct depuis londres
avec paul iwai professeur et titulaire
d'une chaire de virologie à l'école
d'hygiène et de médecine tropicale de
londres c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir polir oeil merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
avez un veau confirmé l'étude publiée
dans la revue zealand 7 sur l'efficacité
de ce vaccin russe une étude réputé
objective indépendante comment at elle
été menée pour bien qu'on comprenne
vaccine initiative très habituel car on
utilise un vecteur à thoune virus qui a
déjà été utilisée par astrazeneca et par
johnson & johnson et par un vaccin
chinois et russe est un vecteur très
accommodante dans les vaccins
beaucoup d'études ont été menées sur le
sujet ne suis pas surprise que et fax
ainsi qu'une grille 5 pour qu'ils créent
soit très efficace car il utilise une
approche légèrement différente avec eux
deux à différer ce différend ce qui veut
dire que l'immunité de la première dos
ne ne faiblit pas celle de la seconde
les autres vaccins à vecteur à des virus
non utilisé qu'un seul par exemple
l'adénovirus ans ou la délivrance 26,58
nycf et utilise les deux virus
multigénique protein spike poutine c'est
ça le virus se sont porteurs du gène de
la lipoprotéine de pointe qui permet à
l'organisme de se protéger contre
l'infection l'adénovirus introduit dans
l'organisme ne peut pas se répliquer il
se contente de produire les protéines
qui sont ensuite enregistrées par le
système immunitaire qui lance une
production
la prochaine fois que le virus arrive
pour contaminer et bien ces protéines
sont complètement bloqués après deux
doses le taux de protection et de 91 6%
à trio placebo d'église delhi le taux de
vaccination lors des essais étaient des
3 pour 1 ayant eu plusieurs milliers de
personnes dans ses essais et il y à eut
pas d'effets secondaires dont certains
furent pas d'effet ce coût d'un crabe
c'est un très bon vaccin
donc effectivement 86 % d'efficacité ça
le place parmi les vaccins les plus
efficaces sur le marché
efficacité sur toutes les catégories
population ya super coach dit oui ils
ont étudié tous les niveaux d'âge à
partir de 18h jusqu'à 60 ans plus de 60
ans et des hommes et des femmes il n'y
avait pas de différence au niveau de la
protection entre les différents âges
donc c'est un vaccin très performant et
je pense que la raison pour cela c'est
qu'ils ont utilisé deux types d'adn aux
virus et pas un seul c'est ce qui fait
sans doute la différence
bien sûr il ya beaucoup d'alluré sur cet
axe là mais ils ont été activés sont pas
vraiment des adénovirus simplement des
vecteurs pour permettre à l'organisme de
produire des anticorps et l'immunité
c'est la société est également très
efficace car cela est produit à
l'intérieur des cellules
c'est un très bon vaccin bref c'est un
vaccin très performant très efficace
comparé aux électrodes aux autres
vaccins adénovirus alors ces nouvelles
sont plutôt très encourageante et
pourtant il ya eu beaucoup de méfiance
on s'en souvient en août dernier quand
la russie annoncé avoir trouvé ce vaccin
et qu'elle allait le produire vous
partagiez ce sentiment comment vous
expliquer cette cette grande méfiance
que beaucoup ont eu à ce moment là nikos
nous donner plus et de briscous des
actus les vacciner dit sans people qui
c'est la façon dont le vaccin était
présente et ils ont commencé à vacciner
des gens en première ligne avant d'avoir
terminé les essais de france 3 dans les
pays occidentaux on ne fait jamais cela
et à l'époque 1600 personnes avaient été
vaccinées et pas de tous les âges et
même à l'époque le taux d'efficacité
était élevé cependant on émet donc pas
cela car tous plus les données n'étaient
pas claires cela manquait de
transparence
une pension qu'il faisait prenez des
raccourcis car il n'était pas aussi à
nautique huleux qu'on peut l'être dans
les pays occidentaux mais maintenant
cette affaire est réglée car à l'étude
publiée dans le lancet
la semaine dernière cette semaine montre
qu'ils ont bien suivi toutes les règles
toutes les réglementations
séraphin de se prouver l'efficacité du
vaccin ce vaccin est tout à fait au même
niveau que les autres produits dans un
temps record ou dernier très rapide
quand on sait que plusieurs vaccins
évidemment mettre des années en c'est
vrai que c'est le cas aussi d'autres
vaccins mais enfin quand même il ya
quelques mois d'écart comment expliquer
cette rapidité chez nos amis russes
bill cosby pro leaders politiques sans
doute pu prendre les décisions et coup
plus rapidement de toutes les nations
leur système régulatoire réglementaire
différent des règles différentes
à suivre et sans doute qu'en russie ils
ont pu aller plus vite de ce point de
vue il faut comprendre que et virus les
vaccins n'a pas des novices ce n'est
rien de niveau astrazeneca on a
développé en chine c'était 15 ans le cas
il est possible d'avoir un bac 5 sans
aucun danger à vecteur admis virus donc
en russie ils ont pu s'appuyer sur ces
résultats et a avancé beaucoup plus
rapidement
necessary ils ont suivi toutes les
étapes nécessaires pour le développement
d'un vaccin
donc je pense que cette rapidité était
dû à la réactivité des organes
régulateurs voulait aller vite et donc
ils sont mis en place un système
accéléré
notre espèce ce week-end nous promettant
que je sache le vaccin ne pousse
pourtant qu'un problème c'est un bon
vaccin est peut-être que cette rapidité
pouvait être perçu comme inquiétante au
début lorsqu'ils ont publié les
résultats des essais de phase 1 et 2
sont assez d'informations mais la
troisième phase est la plus importante
et les données sont très très très
suffisante dernière une dernière
question avant d'être produit et
distribué en europe il faudra obtenir
donc cette fameuse validation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
combien de temps pourrait-elle prendre
selon vous je ne peux pas répondre à
cette question je ne sais pas je ne suis
qu'une scientifique qui a donc je peux
dire ce qui est un bon vaccin ou un
mauvais vaccin mais je pense que cela
pourrait être très rapide car les
données sont très solides et je ne pense
pas que cela posera problème mais je ne
pourrais pas vous dire quand cela sera
fait mais il y a déjà des négociations
avec d'autres pays par exemple avec
l'amérique du sud donc je ne serais pas
surprise
you look si l'europe adopté rapidement
ce vaccin également il n'y aurait aucune
raison contre cela un vaccin c'est un
vaccin s'il est efficace c'est
l'important nous avons besoin d'un très
bon vaccin si rapidement possible merci
le professeur et titulaire d'une chaire
de virologie à l'école déjà
et de médecine tropicale de londres
merci à vous en france à présent le
premier ministre jean castex et son
gouvernement faisait le point sur la
situation sanitaire lié aux kobe 19 pad
annonces majeures mais un appel aux
tests massif et à la prudence
le point avec florian lambert sur ce
qu'il faut en retenir de cette
conférence de presse pas de nouvelles
mesures mais de la prudence
voilà le mot d'ordre de cette conférence
de presse du gouvernement sur la
situation sanitaire en france jugé
toujours préoccupante notamment à cause
des nouveaux variants toujours pas de re
confinement sur le territoire mais en
outre-mer après l'apparition du variant
sud africain les habitants de mayotte
subiront un confinement d'au moins trois
semaines
en france le gouvernement veut éviter
autant que possible leur confinement au
coût économique social et humain
conséquent l'heure est au respect
maximale de nos règles communes
ces règles l'immense majorité d'entre
nous les respecte mais il suffit qu'un
faible nombre s'en affranchissent pour
que le virus prospère un nouveau
confinement ne peut s'envisager qu'en
tout dernier recours
la situation ne justifie pas à ce jour
notre niveau d'incidence est certes
élevé mais il reste encore très
inférieur à ce qu'il était en octobre
dernier alors même que nous dépistons
toujours autant vous disant cela je veux
être clair si nous y sommes contraints
en cas de dégradation forte et rapide de
la situation
nous n'hésiterions pas à prendre nos
responsabilités voulons maintenir la
stratégie tester alerte et protéger le
premier ministre en juin un nouveau les
français à se faire tester massivement
et se dit satisfait de la campagne de
vaccination en france
jean castex la firme l'objectif de
quatre millions de personnes ayant reçu
leur première injection sera atteint
d'ici la fin du mois de février grâce
aux vaccins astrazeneca validé désormais
par la haute autorité de santé 1,7
million de rendez vous supplémentaire
pour la première injection du vaccin
seront
posée aux français dans les prochains
jours nous avons déjà atteint et même
dépassé les premiers objectifs que nous
nous étions fixés
un million et demi de vaccination ont
été réalisées en janvier au lieu d'1
millions prévus initialement
c'est un taux d'adhésion remarquable
preuve que notre stratégie dans ces
établissements était la bonne
enfin jean castex insiste le télétravail
devient impératif lorsque cela est
possible en 24 heures dans le pays
plus de vingt mille nouveaux cas de
contamination ont été enregistrés 1600
personnes sont entrées en
hospitalisation et 300 personnes sont
décédées et pour parler de cette
conférence de presse et de ces annonces
petites annonces en tout cas dans ça
vous avez que gérard omer psychiatre et
médecin chef de l'unité d'accueil de
diagnostic et d'orientation à l'hôpital
sainte-marie de rodez bonsoir gérardmer
merci d'être avec nous vous avez souvent
un tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
notamment sur le suicide des jeunes pas
de confinement c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle si l'on peut dire pour le moral
des français ce soir et des jeunes en
particulier
oui bonsoir on est quelqu'un qui étudie
les moyens importants par rapport aux
capacités encore de résistance lézignan
que nos jeunes de notre pays qui au fil
des périodes de confinement à semi
continent on note dans la consultation
un phénomène d'épuisement de renault
renoncement avec des attitudes de
soumission un petit peu à des
envahissements monsieur des éléments
dépressif qui apparaissent et perdure et
des menaces suicidaire événements
semblent se présenter
nous n'avons pas constaté encore
d'augmentation franche sympathie de
celui-ci nous augmentons c'est une
augmentation du trouble anxieux mais de
manière très important une augmentation
des périodes et précis pour l'instant
nos jeunes sont au travail deux buts
contre le processus psychiques
mais pour autant une inquiétude pour
leur avenir et surtout lié un grand
manque de repères et d'incertitudes
c'est ça qui nous verbaliser plus de la
consultation c'est gagner d'accord on
vient du temps on a vu gérard au maire
dans des manifestations chez nos voisins
européens un petit vent de révolte avec
des ouvertures clandestine ici ou là de
restaurants des fêtes sauvages une
révolte sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment est ce que la population d'une
manière générale est de moins en moins
encline à supporter les mesures de
restriction et d'une certaine manière
est plutôt prête à prendre le risque du
virus finalement alors moi je ne dirais
pas comme ça vous avez dû entendre d'un
héros dit qu'ils avaient au niveau de la
population qu'il est tout récent
champion du monde hier k-fed est à peu
près de 55% des français demandent un
confinement au moment mystique où le
gouvernement nous laisse encore espérer
une zone de risque même à laquelle on
n'est pas encore à devoir être dans un
continent ce qui met polyera la pensée
qui va derrière ce questionnaire s'est
demandé un confinement fort la pensée
c'est une dernière fois et ensuite être
libéré et est soulagé comme une forme de
guérison dans un film inscrit dessus
peut malheureusement personne
c'est intéressant parce que ça veut dire
en fait on est prêt à accepter pire
encore pire de souffrir d'un coup mais
que ça soit complètement fini
après ça veut dire qu'au gouvernement de
ce point de vue là c'est propre plutôt
mal non c'est parce que je dis que j'ai
dit et dans le fonctionnement
psychologique les personnes disent on
est prêt à aller vers un confinement
plus dur que ce que vos gouvernements
demandent actuellement cette volonté
encore plus restrictive de leur liberté
est liée entre est un espoir pour
l'instant personne avec certitude
après c'est de continuer à inscrire 17 6
semaines qui se fait de moi mais voilà
comme une unité
on retrouverait 7 gilbert qui a récupéré
cette liberté d'aller et venir
on se serait ce sentiment d'incertitude
qui sont les deux piliers psychologique
qui nous fragilise ou en ce moment alors
il ya une autre annonce celle
d'elizabeth board qui veut non pas
maintenir mais augmenter encore
davantage le télétravail avec notamment
une ligne d'écouté pour les salariés
parce que la situation est difficile
pour eux aussi ce télétravail sacré
également de gros dégâts psychologiques
sur certaines personnes j'ai bien le
télétravail est plus compliqué une jeune
mieux supporter
plus on est dans une structuration une
sécurité professionnelle le télétravail
est très important pour se protéger des
crises sanitaires et je ne remettais
sûrement pas en cause maintenant il faut
réellement une organisation et une
hygiène de vie il faut appliquer à côté
du télétravail
si on peut arriver à le supporter parce
que malgré tous les efforts entrepris
dans l'est forcément cette relation
sociale dans notre onze seulement
psychologique on a tous
alors ce soir il y avait une fois n'est
pas coutume la présence du ministre de
l'intérieur à cette conférence de presse
gérald darmanin qui a insisté sur le
renforcement des contrôles écoutez j'ai
demandé aux forces de l'ordre d'être
particulièrement vigilants sur le sujet
des fêtes et des restaurants dits
clandestins et en premier lieu de leurs
organisateurs
ces événements de plus en plus fréquents
alors que nous savons qu'il favorise la
diffusion du virus peuvent anéantir tous
les efforts collectifs
on imagine que ces fêtes clandestines
chez les jeunes justement c'était en
quelque sorte des soupapes ça va être
compliqué ces contrôles renforcés mais
installé passée par là je pense que
techniquement il est difficile de faire
accepter à une population des efforts
importants qu'une petite partie d'entre
elles et des conduite irresponsable le
besoin de se rencontrer de partager de
cette proximité fait partie du
développement de l'adolescent avait
besoin d'eux le fait est important mais
par contexte actuel il est
responsables et des jeunes même si
effectivement ils sont moins exposées
sont tout comme les autres des porteurs
et des transmetteurs du virus qui
peuvent aller vers des proches et des
proches plus fragiles qui ne veut peut
aller jusqu'à la décision en réanimation
voir un non retour donc effectivement
c'est quelque chose n'importe quel moi
je suis personnellement très vite et
soutenir tout en étant psychiatre est
bien conscient de la souffrance
psychologique aux nos jeunes je voudrais
dire aussi d'importants parce qu'on
parle beaucoup des jeunes mais une étude
est sorti aussi là dessus sur une
statistique sur les violences
intraconjugales mais ça je le rencontre
aussi pendant mon travail d'expert
d'expertisé judiciaire dans le milieu
carcéral où je travaillais sur mon
service d'urgence ce sont des hommes qui
deviennent violents voire ce contexte et
des violences qui sont faites on joue un
coup son exemple merci en tout cas
gérardmer évidemment force est la
précision dont on parle souvent ici ou
là
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
au psychiatre et médecin chef de l'unité
d'accueil de diagnostic et d'orientation
à l'hôpital sainte-marie de rodez grève
nationale et manifestations partout en
france aujourd'hui notamment à paris
plusieurs secteurs se sont mobilisés
dans la capitale entre les places de la
république et de la nation pour l'emploi
les salaires et le service public
parmi les manifestants des syndicats des
organisations de la jeunesse et des
acteurs du monde de la culture notamment
le point avec maxime appelle les mesures
sanitaires n'ont pas fait taire les
revendications
environ vingt mille personnes ont défilé
selon la cgt entre les places de la
république et de la nation à paris
cette période particulière les questions
sociales elles peuvent pas de mise sous
la table et donc il faut que la colère
qu'on croise tous les jours qu'il y a
dans les entreprises elles puissent
exprimer donc c'est un appel à agir or
il faut que nos revendications sont
attendues parmi ces revendications une
politique de relocalisation industrielle
le développement des services publics ou
encore l'interdiction des licenciements
dans les entreprises qui ont bénéficié
des aides publiques
le gouvernement prétend que qu'ils
gèrent la crise selon le bon sens est en
réalité tout ça est quand même en train
de se craqueler derrière le bon sens il
ya des choix qui sont pas porteurs
d'avenir
selon philippe martin et 165 initiatives
ont eu lieu dans toute la france à paris
donc à marseille mais aussi à lyon où
entre deux à trois mille personnes
s'étaient réunies relais dans un moment
où l'état déversé des centaines de
milliards dans les caisses des
actionnaires du cac 40
la collectivité francs contre le chômage
partiel les mêmes organisés les
licenciements massifs
la remise en cause du droit du travail
notamment par le biais des accords de
performance collective et par dessus
sans résultat une classe général de nos
services publics et de la misère noire
c'est le maigre s'accroît parce qu'avant
on parlait de ont parlé des sans-abri
disait malraux les 16 av et mènerait
sait pas que les sans-abri
malheureusement ça se développe dans la
jeunesse chez les retraités et dans les
missions de service public
eux sont parmi les plus touchés par les
conséquences de la pandémie les acteurs
culturels les professeurs et les
étudiants s'étaient joints au cortège
on veut une réouverture des packs dans
des bonnes conditions sanitaires avec un
respect des protocoles sanitaires les
étudiants
leur appartement ils sont sales et dans
ce contexte sanitaire morose pas de
mobilisation massive
même si les syndicats se félicitent de
la participation le contexte économique
lui n'a rien de rassurant
on compte 85 mille rupture de contrat en
france rien qu'en janvier
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'espagne l'un des
pays les plus touchés par le cos vide
qui refuse de recourir à l'armé ultime
du confinement et poursuit un objectif
70 % de vacciner avant l'été puis ce
sera les dites aux échos sur la chasse
de ces fameux vaccin certains pays
semblent mieux lotis que d'autres cela
peut-il retarder la reprise économique
jacques sapir tentera dirait
[Musique]
nous sommes dans une évolution
concurrentiel permanente dans laquelle
chacun essaie d'améliorer ses positions
tout en déstabilisant août à des
démonstrations de force les guerre
frontale entre hyperpuissance deviennent
très incertain la guerre économique
évolue rapidement pour répondre aux
besoins dans tous les domaines
d'activité stratégiques ou d'importance
vitale
c'est cette évolution devenue évidente
qui va obliger nos organisations
internationales à se reconstruire ou à
disputer le contrôle du numérique est
une clé majeure du contrôle des peuples
des nations
celui qui vend ni qui en connaît le
fonctionnement et peut en tirer des
avantages multi qu au plan offensif et
défense
dans cette guerre économique secrète et
sans merci il faut savoir se défend et
souvent attaqués pour survivre
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement a percuté et on ne peut
pas considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et notre étude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france
l'allemagne va-t-elle déjà des confiné
alors que les mesures se sont durcies il
y a deux semaines avec un troisième
confinement la question semble pourtant
se poser les chiffres des nouveaux cas
sont en baisse et le nombre de morts
chaque jour semble se stabiliser alors
est ce possible l'allemagne peut-elle
déjà ceux des confiné au coeur de la
troisième vague de kobe 19 éléments de
réponse avec maxime a bola écoles bars
restaurants commerces non alimentaires
depuis début janvier ils sont tous
fermés en allemagne
s'ajoute un télétravail dans la mesure
du possible une stricte limitation des
rencontres
objectif contrer l'épidémie de covin 19
qui a connu une recrudescence au début
de l'année
le gouvernement allemand a préféré agir
vite avec un nouveau confinement des
mesures qui semblent déjà porter leurs
fruits nous ne pouvons pas rester dans
ce confinement dur tout l'hiver
notre société ne le supporterais pas
bien il n'est pas possible de se
prononcer avec certitude sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouverons le 14 février
les chiffres sont encourageants nous
observons une tendance significative à
la baisse concernant les nouvelles
infections
le taux d'incidence est en effet en
baisse en allemagne le nombre moyen de
nouvelles infections pour 100000
habitants est passé à 87 ce jeudi et se
rapproche du seuil des 50 souhaité par
les autorités
à titre de comparaison le taux
d'incidence en france et 2 213% mille
habitants et de 700 au portugal l'un des
pays les plus touchés
la campagne de vaccination allemande est
aussi efficace avec plus de 2,7 millions
de personnes qui ont reçu une première
dose
l'allemagne est le pays de l'union
européenne le plus en avance des
chiffres qui amène à réfléchir sur un
possible d confinement des personnes
vaccinées une possibilité aussitôt
réfutée il faut espérer que les taux
d'infection diminueront considérablement
grâce à la vaccination
toutefois des infections continueront à
se produire malgré les vaccinations
cela doit être clairement communiqué les
demandes d'exemption des restrictions la
libye
td personnes vaccinées ne sont pas très
utiles ici
elle suggère la fausse sécurité selon
laquelle les personnes vaccinées ne
présente pas de risque d'infection
sir déconfinement semble encore dans les
papiers du gouvernement allemand rien
n'est encore fait concrètement plusieurs
virologues ont mis en garde contre une
sortie prématurée du confinement en
raison du risque posé par les variantes
du virus plus transmissible et de plus
l'allemagne est le dixième pays le plus
touché au monde par le cos vide en terme
de mortalité avec plus de soixante mille
décès depuis le début de l'épidémie et
l'espagne l'un des pays d'europe les
plus touchés par la pandémie a franchi
hier la barre des 60 mille décès duo
kobe 19 des autorités veulent accélérer
la campagne de vaccination les
précisions de notre correspondante à
barcelone l'espagne n'a pas les moyens
d'assurer un nouveau confinement le
gouvernement s'inquiète de la situation
économique et il a été très clair il n'a
pas les finances pour une telle mesure
alors les conséquences du premier
confinement en mars dernier ont été
dramatiques
l'espagne ne pourrait pas verser de
nouvelles indemnités chômage ni des
aides aux entreprises alors néanmoins la
ministre de la santé a demandé aux
régions de prendre plus de mesures pour
freiner la propagation du coronavirus il
faut qu'elle fasse le maximum pour faire
baisser les chiffres ce sont les mots
qu'elle a employé car les médecins de
leur côté tire la sonnette d'alarmé
le système de santé sature dans
certaines régions ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à demander le confinement
car le taux d'occupation des patients
atteints de coronaropathie 16
d'augmenter il est de 26% dans les
hôpitaux et de 45% en soins intensifs
alors l'espagne est le pays européen
ayant le plus de cas à de la variante
britannique et pour en parler de ce cas
espagnol nous sommes avec philippe
emmanueli médecins français exerçant en
espagne bonsoir philippe allemagne
vous retrouver pour évoquer donc cette
situation en espagne on a vu les
chiffres malheureusement son sont guère
reluisants et pourtant à l'instar de la
france d'ailleurs pas d'heureux
confinement c'est quoi c'est l'économie
qui prime on a fait ce choix là bas
aussi
bonsoir stéphanie de murs rue ben il ya
eu un petit peu une commune une
confusion dans sur ce sujet parce que
cette référence à l'incapacité
économique de l'espagne
évidemment nema n'est pas une autorité
gouvernementale c'est ce sont des
commentaires effectivement qui ont été
diffusées dans la presse qui ont été
largement repris au niveau européen mais
ce n'est pas la lecture qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui moi j'aurai une lecture plus
optimiste qui est celle que le l'espagne
et le gouvernement espagnol ont vraiment
trouvé juste mesure juste compromis
entre la préservation des activités
économiques de son pays et les gestes
barrières et on en voit les résultats
c'est un pari qui est en passe d'être
gagné car finalement aujourd'hui les
chiffres qui ont été annoncés
aujourd'hui montrent une d'une
régression du virus en espagne et les
restaurants sont ouverts
on annonce même la réouverture des
librairies le week end
l'élargissement des périmètres de
circulation du niveau municipal haut
niveau comme arcade qui est ce qui en
fait que qui valenduc en torrent france
donc on voit bien que derrière
effectivement ces commentaires
politiques qui ont eu lieu sur la
capacité de l'allemagne à dire est à
venir en appui économique des activités
il ya une réalité qui est le respect
effectivement des petits commerçants des
activités de tous les jours et qui
aujourd'hui effectivement fonctionne
alors là vous nous intéressait philippe
emmanuelli parce que j'entends déjà nos
restaurateurs français faire mais bon ça
veut dire que vous nous dit en substance
les chiffres là en tout cas les tout
récents sont plutôt encourageants malgré
tout les restaurants restent ouverts à
ses obligations
oui je vous le confirme je vous le
confirme aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le
gouvernement espagnol a mis en place une
politique chirurgicale c'est à dire que
ouverture des restaurants s'est fait sur
des bases très précises premièrement de
plages horaires
deuxièmement de protocole sanitaire
troisièmement de concentration des
patients dans les restaurants et ça
fonctionne les restaurants ouvrent deux
fois par jour sur des plages horaires
réduite mais qui leur permettent
d'assurer environ 2 service par plages
horaires et ça ne se traduit pas
aujourd'hui par une augmentation des
contaminations
ça veut dire que l'étape sont espacées
comment ça se passe concrètement parce
que je vous cache pas que ça nous
intrigue un petit peu parce que c'est
quand même incroyable pays voisin
l'espagne la france nous dit bah non
c'est dans les restaurants qu'on se
contaminent plus parce que forcément
interactions sociales donc tout et son
contraire
oui c'est un petit peu ça et puis c'est
vrai aussi que les études ne sont pas là
pour véritablement tranché dans un sens
ou dans un autre parce qu'il ya toujours
une nouvelle étude est sorti
scientifique qui est à nouveau a
contredit le fait que les restaurants
était un lieu de contamination
l'expérience espagnole montre
aujourd'hui que le fait de continuer à
une restauration avec encadré avec
effectivement une politique je dirais
dédiée à cette activité économique
fonctionne et il ya également le
triptyque est en tête ester protéger
isolé
jamais si je le dis dans le bon sens
pardonnez moi c'est le cas également en
espagne on continue a testé massivement
toujours les tests pcr où on a ouvert
justement à d'autres formes de tests à
écouter aujourd'hui on est massivement
mais l'ambiance est clairement à la
vaccination est aujourd'hui le directeur
de la santé dans sa conférence de presse
a annoncé que l'ensemble des
pensionnaires de maisons de retraite
étaient vaccinés dans leur totalité et
c'est un grand soulagement ici parce
qu'on sait que manifestement ça va se
traduire effectivement dans les courbes
de mortalité dans les prochaines
semaines est leur objectif 70 % de
vacciner avant l'été ça vous semble
crédit possible il était manuel dit on
sait combien il ya de problèmes de
pénurie de vaccins en europe
oui écoutez l'espagne pour le moment
fait la course en tête puisque lé
environ le cinquième ou sixième pays en
avance dans la vaccination de sa
population elle et elle devance
notamment largement la france avec
environ 3 5% de la population
actuellement vaccinés contre environ
2,86 % la population en france
donc oui l'espagne a vraiment la volonté
d'atteindre cet objectif et vous le
savez est bien effectivement l'arrivée
en force du vaccin scouts nique dans la
course au vaccin disponible
effectivement ici suscite de nouveaux
espoirs
oui effectivement le gouvernement
espagnol qui s'est dit disposé utiliser
spoutnik v ça veut dire que l'espagne
aussi attend avec une forme d'impatience
la validation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
eh bien oui spoutnik est en passe de
devenir l'un des vaccins les plus sexy
de l'union européenne et aujourd'hui
plus rien ne s'oppose à l'arrivée de
spoutnik si ce n'est effectivement
l'autorisation de l' agence européenne
mais on voit bien qu'ici les autorités
espagnoles seront les premières à
réclamer ce vaccin s'il agence du
médicament européen le valide
merci en tout cas philippe emmanueli
médecin français exerçant en espagne
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer donc
la situation espagnole merci à vous et
en amérique du sud à présent quatre
mille nouveaux cas quotidiens en moyenne
le shimmy entame cette semaine une
vaccination de masse bilan de la
première journée 140 mille doses
administrées
pour l'heure les nombreux centres à
travers le pays accueille uniquement des
personnes âgées a maille à soulever la
campagne ambitieuse du chili a débuté ce
mercredi alors que le pays a reçu 4
millions de doses du vaccin chinois
sinovac une campagne massive avec pour
objectif que cent mille personnes soient
vaccinés chaque jour d'ici à la fin mars
ce qui représente les 5 millions de
citoyens les plus vulnérables du pays
avec environ 500 vaccination le premier
jour nous avons rencontré quelques
problèmes logistiques duo flux de
patients mais nous les avons résolus
demain nous espérons travailler beaucoup
mieux le stade municipal de la floride a
fait partie des 1400 centres de
vaccination que compte le pays
un calendrier a été mise en place par
les autorités sanitaires
parmi les premiers à recevoir leur
injection les plus de 90 ans
puis les hauts responsables de la santé
les étudiants en pratique clinique ou
encore les personnels et réside en
maison de retraite
le vaccin est accueilli à bras ouverts
par le ministre de la santé henrique
parisse et par la population
aujourd'hui était un grand jour pour le
chili la vaccination de masse signifie
une journée joyeuse pleine d'émotion et
d'espoir pour tout le monde mais surtout
pour nos aînés ici ma mère a déjà été
vaccinées nous avons fait le processus
d'attentes
ils sont entrés dans le box et elle est
allée se faire vacciner tout seul
et de là ils ont pris ces informations
et ils nous ont donné cette carte afin
que nous puissions revenir pour la
deuxième dose la date qu'ils nous ont
donnée le 3 mars
donc nous devons revenir pour obtenir la
deuxième dose afin que le vaccin soit
complet grâce à un nouvel accord avec
sinovac
le chili prévoit d'ici mars de recevoir
13 millions de doses supplémentaires
pour vacciner 70 % de sa population
d'ici à l'été
en décembre déjà le personnel de santé
des unités de soins intensifs
recevez les premières doses du vaccin
riser bio n tech
aujourd'hui le pays compte donc bientôt
210000 vacciner en parallèle à ces
accords passés avec pfizer bio n tech et
sinovac santiago compte également sur le
vaccin américain johnson and johnson et
sur le suédo britannique astrazeneca et
après l'espoir due à l'arrivée des
vaccins contre le coc vidler de la
pénurie les commandes des grands pays
européens se réduit à mesure que les
laboratoires et organise leur production
pour répondre à la demande
certains comme le royaume uni semble
épargnée alors que d'autres comme la
france par exemple voient leurs
campagnes de vaccination retardée alors
comment expliquer de tels écarts ces
retards dans les vaccins compromettent
id la reprise économique
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques aymes bienvenue sur son
sort c'est fini à distance toujours
alors nous avions abordé déjà la
question des vaccins jacques il ya trois
semaines que révèle la pénurie actuelle
voulait il est clair que nous sommes
maintenant dans une situation de pénurie
il est aussi très clair que cette
situation elle découle des besoins en
millions voire en milliards de doses
pour pouvoir vacciner le plus de monde
possible et des capacités de production
des laboratoires alors derrière cela il
ya aussi la question des stratégies
d'achat des doses ces stratégies ont été
différente de pays à pays
certains ont été plus efficaces que
d'autres et puis aussi les stratégies
des laboratoires qui vont jouer beaucoup
dans ce domaine alors jacques commençons
par le commencement pourquoi ça nous
confronter à cette situation de pénurie
de vaccins si vous voulez c'est très
simple nous avons aujourd'hui dans le
monde environ 8 milliards 4 d'habitants
si nous souhaitons que 70% soit vaccinée
ça veut dire qu'il faudra que nous
vaccinons entre cinq et demi et 6
milliards d'ici la fin de l'année
autrement dit il faudra fournir entre 11
et 12 milliards de doses si on regarde
le cas de la france
bon sur la france le la même proportion
pour atteindre l'immunité vaccinale
simply de vacciner 45 millions de
personnes 45 millions de personnes ça
implique aussi 90 millions de doses
on en est très loin aujourd'hui avec le
rythme de livraison de deux millions et
demi de doses par mois
il nous faudrait 36 mois si nous
doublons il nous faudrait encore 18 mois
c'est clairement inacceptable il
faudrait que l'on puisse atteindre un
rythme de livraisons de l'ordre de 9 à
10 millions de doses par mois pour
pouvoir faire ce programme complet de
vaccination j'en reviens à ma question
pourquoi cette pénurie
alors cette pénurie elle a plusieurs
causes
tout d'abord il ya le problème
de l'organisation de la production et du
soutien que les états ont pu apporter ça
il ya des états comme le royaume uni
comme les etats-unis qui ont beaucoup
aidés les laboratoires et là on voit
qu'il ya peut-être une différence avec
l'union européenne
et puis il ya la question des stratégies
d'achat les etats unis la grande
bretagne ont décidé de payer sans
rechigner
même chose pour israël qui non seulement
accepté de payer un certain surcoût pour
avoir des vaccins mais elle a même
accepté de transférer les données
sanitaires de l'ensemble de ses citoyens
vacciner au laboratoire pfizer
c'est une pratique qui est discutable je
n'en disconviens pas mais qui s'est
révélé quand même très efficace alors
et pour ce qui est de l'union européenne
alors la stratégie de l'union européenne
on voit bien qu'elle a été très
différente la stratégie d'union
européenne ça a été de dire si nous
voulons pouvoir acheter au meilleur prix
si nous voulons pouvoir peser sur les
laboratoires il faut que l'on achète
groupe et c'était pas idiot d'ailleurs
simplement ça entraîné un niveau d'abord
de lourdeurs bureaucratiques un niveau
de rigidité dans la capacité à passer d
or ce qui fait que l'union européenne
n'a pu intervenir n'a pu se positionner
en acheteurs qu environ trois mois après
le royaume uni si on prend simplement le
cas des pays européens est évidemment ce
retard maintenant il devient cumulatif
on voit très bien que tel que cela
fonctionne aujourd'hui
grosso modo 60 voire 70 % des doses ne
seront pas livrés avant l'été voit avant
la fin du deuxième semestre 2021 donc
nous aurons énormément de mal à pouvoir
atteindre cet objectif de vaccination
des 70% de la population
ça entraîne parfois des conflits
notamment entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni illustration avec le vaccin
d'astrazeneca
oui tout à fait c'est un très bon
exemple c'est fini alors astrazeneca a
été massivement aidées par le
gouvernement britannique
et là si vous voulez ça d'abord permis
astrazeneca de développer ses capacités
mais en échange évidemment le
gouvernement britannique a exigé
d'astrazeneca un effet ce de contrat de
priorité pour les doutes qui sont
produites en grande bretagne et ça c'est
un point extrêmement important
le gouvernement britannique d'ailleurs
procédé exactement de la même manière
avec vous savez cette start-up
franco-autrichienne val neva qui va elle
aussi qui d'abord il soutenu par le
gouvernement qui lui a payé la
construction d'une nouvelle usine qui va
quand elle l'aura l'homologation pour
son vaccin livrer 100 millions de doses
en priorité en grande-bretagne alors on
voit bien ici le problème de la
stratégie adoptée par l'union européenne
l'union européenne n'a pas été du tout
dans cette stratégie
elle s'est montrée trop rigide trop
lourde
elle n'a pas été capable de saisir toute
une série d'opportunités dont par
exemple le cas de vannes et va et le
résultat c'est que aujourd'hui elle est
très largement distancé par le royaume
uni mais alors jacques comment sortir de
la pénurie
alors si vous voulez la meilleure
réponse à la pénurie
c'est évidemment la question de
l'organisation de la production
il n'y a pas de ce point de vue là deux
miracles alors le premier point
évidemment c'est qu'il va falloir
encourager les coopérations entre les
différents laboratoires
notez d'ailleurs que ça c'est alors on a
beaucoup parlé de l'accord entre pfizer
et sanofi bon c'est un accord qui porte
plutôt sur l'emballage
ce qu'on appelle le flaconnage mais en
fait c'est déjà un accord qui peut d'une
certaine manière à accélérer la
production il y à un autre accord
important dont on a très peu parlé
c'est l'accord qui était passé entre
astrazeneca et l'institut russe gamaleya
autour de spoutnik 5 et qui pourrait
évidemment ouvrir un des potentialités
une fois que ce pique nique 5 sera
homologué en europe
donc ça c'est le premier prix deuxième
point c'est la question des licences
ouvert et là il faut bien faire une
distinction entre les licences ouvertes
qui sont des licences qui sont rachetés
par les états aux différents
laboratoires et des licences libres qui
serait une certaine manière fait que les
gouvernements obligent les laboratoires
à mettre librement en axé leurs vaccins
et la formule de leurs vaccins alors ce
processus des licences ouvertes il a
déjà été historiquement utilisé en
particulier pour les médicaments contre
le sida
on sait que c'est quelque chose qui
marche on sait que c'est quelque chose
qui ne laisse pas fondamentalement les
laboratoires tout en permettant
effectivement une production / très
grande échelle mais malheureusement
c'est un processus qui prend du temps
après il ya une troisième chose hélas si
vous voulez c'est intéressant il
faudrait peut-être que l'on regarde ce
qui a été fait par les états unis
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale parce
que il faut savoir que les états unis
ont un système de planification oui on
peut parler d'une planification qui a
été extrêmement efficace et dans cette
planification en fait chaque fois qu'un
producteur d'avion qu'un chantier naval
et état avait une baisse de plan de
charge
eh bien on lui transférer la production
d'autres dossiers que on
l'avionneur pouvait produire des avions
qui avait été conçu par un autre avion
honneur par exemple des boeing ont été
produits par lockheed des lockheed ont
des produits par curtis ou par
république et c'est bien ça c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
qui tout comme le choix des
sous-traitants pouvait être d'une
certaine manière désignés par l'état et
là on voit bien que si le commissariat
au plan qui a été recréée en septembre
dernier
si le commissariat au plan avait quelque
chose à faire
ce serait tout à fait cela alors ces
pénuries qui vont durer malheureusement
encore un certain temps
la question qu'on se pose à ce qu'elles
ne vont pas compromettre la reprise
économique
ça malheureusement on peut le craindre
d'ores et déjà l'allemagne a abaissé ses
perspectives de croissance
les perspectives de croissance à la fin
de l'année au mois de décembre dernier
elle était de 5,5 pour cent pour l'année
2000 21
aujourd'hui elles sont ramenées à 33.5 %
bon c'est quand même une baisse de 2%
il ya le même processus qui est déjà en
cours en france on révise à la baisse
les prévisions pour 2021
plus globalement plus le l'épidémie va
durer si vous voulez plus longtemps on
mettra atteindre justement cette
immunité vaccinale donc à vacciner
grosso modo les 70 % de notre population
est plus longtemps l'économie
travaillera au ralenti qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire tout d'abord que
l'europe l'union européenne va prendre
un retard important par rapport à
d'autres pays occidentaux qui eux ont
mieux géré cette question que ce soit
les états unis que ce soit la grande
bretagne mais surtout qu'elle va
accumuler du retard avec les pays
asiatiques qui eux semblent d'ores et
déjà être sorti de cette phase de crise
liée à l'épidémie de covile 10
et pour conclure jacques à quoi peut-on
s'attendre sur le front des vaccins
alors un moyen terme il faut très
clairement être optimiste de nombreux
vaccins vont apparaître
il ya évidemment le cas de spoutnik 5
qui est un vaccin en fait beaucoup plus
simple à utiliser que le kaiser et le et
le modern art il est comparable à
l'astra zeneca sauf qu'il est plus
efficace que l'astra et des cas ce qui
explique d'ailleurs peut-être l'accord
qui a été signé entre astrazeneca et le
laboratoire gamaleya donc on peut être
plutôt optimiste à moyen terme même si
je ne pense pas que l'on tiendra
l'objectif d'une vaccination de 70% de
la population d'ici le mois de septembre
pour l'instant ça ne me semble
absolument pas possible
par contre le véritable problème qui va
se poser c'est la vaccination dans les
pays en développement ou en voie de
développement dans les pays pauvres et
dans les pays très pauvres parce que si
vous voulez il faut ça il faut
comprendre une chose ça n'a pas de sens
de vouloir atteindre justement cette
situation d'immunité vaccinale dans les
pays développés on les sent le virus se
développe est lui aussi dans les pays
pauvres et très pauvres qui représentent
quand même un énorme ensemble de monde
que ce soit en afrique
que ce soit en amérique latine que ce
soit au moyen-orient que ce soit en asie
centrale et donc de ce point de vue là
c'est quelque chose qui est à la fois
moralement insupportable
tout le monde devrait avoir droit au
vaccin c'est clair mais qui est surtout
inefficaces d'un point de vue sanitaire
parce que cela donnerait la possibilité
au virus de venir nous réinfectés et
surtout ça voudrait dire que le virus
aurait toujours la possibilité de
continuer ses différentes mutations et
on verrait à ce moment là d'autres
variantes d'évasion peut-être africains
latino américains moyen-orientaux
apparaître régulièrement
donc c'est ça d'une certaine manière le
grand défi des mois qui viennent ce sont
donc jacques des choix véritablement
stratège
qui s'imposent pour sortir de cette
pandémie merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine
et c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]